[Applaudissements]
merci d'être avec nous il est 20h21 on
est sur Direct touche pas mon poste
merci d'être là chéri on rigole beaucoup
pendant la pub également avec Raymond
Guillaume et et Géraldine Galine qui
nous a raconté une anecdote
incroyable sur un de ses
ex bravo Géraldine tu es extrêmement
drôle on va passer à ce sujet vous avez
vu ce qu'a dit Emmanuel Macron sur
l'Ukraine il a dit qu'on il appelle à
accélérer l'aide à l'Ukraine peu importe
eff ESV d'accord avec lui regarde ce qu'
dit le
président
voilà donc apparemment le président
pense qu'il faut manger des
birid non Jean-Michel bah non il dit on
plus termine dans cûte que cûte bah non
c'est pas coûte que cûte je voilà
justement ça un coup et ça ça pénalise
je trouve les Français voilà et on est à
l'heure où on est obligé de gérer les
crises les crises en France notamment
les paysans qui en plus on donne on
donne au à l'Ukraine et les paysans
ils'arrêent pas d'ouvrir des camions
c'est des produits qui arrivent
d'Ukraine dans des conditions qui qui
qui pénalisent complètement nos
agriculteurs je trouve qu'on a déjà
beaucoup donné un moment faut savoir se
modérer voilà les autres donnent à ce
momentl 50 milliards d'euros hein c'est
ce qui est en train d'être discuté on
est en train de donner ou prêter 50
milliards d'euros à l'Ukraine alors la
Hongrie est rétiscente mais si c'est
accéléré encore plus d'aide non au bout
d'un moment il faut moi je trouve queon
a complètement renoncé à tous les
processus de paix à un moment il faut
que cette guerre s'arrête quoi on peut
pas donner donner donner 50 milliards
par an pendant des années c'est
impossible pour moi il y a des priorités
effectivement les agriculteurs les
enseignants les infirmiers tous les
secteurs en crise à un moment je pense
qu'il faut repenser nos priorités et là
accélérer encore je trouve que c'est une
escalade de dons qu'on n'est pas en
mesure d'assurer alors celle le plus
grand défenseuse du wioui c'est Valérie
benim donc on va l'écouter parce qu'elle
a la même cil des Ukrainiens je crois
oui maintenant malheureusement parce
qu'ils ont enfin ils ont ils étaient à
cerçon ils sont à cerçon ah d'accord ils
ontéer par qu'il vou continuer à se
battre pour le pays donc voilà et
malheureusement l'un d'entrex a perdu sa
petite fille voil pendant le conflitors
donc voilà et c'est pour la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs je dis qu'il faut
continuer à aider à aider l'Ukraine je
suis d'accord avec lui j'entends que
c'est extrêmement compliqué pour les
Français que ça peut être inaudible
d'entendre peu importe les efforts je
crois qu'on a malheureusement pas le
choix de continuer à les aider parce que
bah Poutine teste nos démocraties et il
faut qu'on qu'on ait une réponse forte
nous les démocraties face à Poutine ça
c'est la première chose et et par
ailleurs je pense qu'il il faut aussi
faire preuve de pédagogie et expliquer
que parfois c'est très facile de dire
c'est la faute à l'raine on narrête pas
d'entendre on l'a dit ici sur ce plateau
notamment Bruno Le Maire a dit
l'électricité c'est la faute à l'Ukraine
on a bien vu que c'était pas la faute à
l'Ukraine en vrai donc à chaque fois on
croit que on prend on donne à l'Ukraine
et on retire au français et ce n'est pas
aussi simple que ça le l'équation est
pas vrai merci Valérie un pe oui Raymon
parce que Raymon c'est lu Mo moi moi
j'étais content quand au début j'étais
content entre guillemets quand dit il
faut aider l'Ukraine en février là j'ai
d allez on aide l'Ukraine on m'a dit
vous'inquiétez pas dans un mois tous les
oligarques vont tous se mettre contre
Poutine les grandes sociétés McDo KFC
tout le monde s'en va il y aura plus
d'essence les Russes ils vont crever de
faim vous allez voir c'est vite fait
c'est un mois 2 mois allez on va compter
6 mois et on va faire l'effort on a mis
des drapeaux partout de l'Ukraine les
France Télé machin il y avait des
drapeaux de l'Ukraine sur toutes les
chaînes autour des stades de foot j'ai
allez on est l'Ukraine ça va aller vite
parce qu'on est le monde entier avec
l'Ukraine donc ça va aller vite he les
Russes ça va ça va vite être réglé on va
augmenter le coût de la vie des Français
c'est pas pas grave allez on le fait
l'effort parce qu'on demande toujours
aux Français de faire l'effort à chaque
fois les hommes politiques je vais
demander aux Français de faire l'effort
je vais demander aux Français de donner
aux associations je vais demander au
français de donner mais un moment donné
regarde 50 milliards moi je pense que
aujourd'hui on n pas les moyens de
donner 50 milliards à
l'UC tout seul 50 Milard
c'est mais me dis pas qu'on a pas donné
des milliards donné combien a passé
milliard on a doné des milliard
con des pays européens qui av le moins
mais on a on a passé le milliard je
pense je pense qu'on a passé le milliard
donc est-ce qu'on a les moyens de le
faire ça fait déjà 2 ans donc moi je dis
que on trouve pas d'argent pour telle ou
telle cause tous les soirs vous me dites
il y a pas d'argent moi je vous dis
l'argent quand on veut le trouver on le
trouve et là bizarrement on trouve de
l'argent je veux bien les aider mais si
ça fait comme la guerre en Afghanistan
si ça fait comme les États-Unis
soit-disant on va partir faire la guerre
il y aura plus de taliban est-ce que
aujourd'hui il y a plus de taliban
est-ce auj'hui il y a plus de taliban il
a des talibans donc je veux bien
qu'onasse la guerre mais va durer
combien de temps cette guerre 2 ans 3
ans 5 ans moi je suis pas d'accord pour
que cette guerre dure 5 ans aller
chercher putine si c'est Poutine le
problème alleer chercher mais me dites
pas on va se bagarer comme ça pendant
des années à dépenser de l'oseille
m'intéresse pas moi pardon mais on a un
cours de géopollytique je connais
rien as
raisone mais la question c'est à partir
de quel moment on décide d'arrêter
d'aider un peuple en fait c'était pas le
galdine juste je te coupe c'était pas le
but d'aller chercher ptine ist le but
c'était pas d'aller chercher non non
réponds-moi juste sur ça est-ce que
c'était le but d'aller chercher Poutine
il y a 2
ans France n jamais voulu être en guerre
contre ptin et toujours
toujours France n' jamaisé des sans avec
la
Russ d'c mais
j'aiend ok donc à partir de quel moment
décide d'arrêter d'aider un peuple à à
partir de quel moment c'estàdire que si
là par exemple nous on dit nous c'est
bon l'Ukraine c'est bon on s'en lave les
mains on en a rien à [__] Poutine peut
prendre l'Ukraine on s'en fout ça veut
dire que quelque part c'est un signal
catastrophique ça veut dire que Poutine
est beaucoup trop fort et nous nous les
démocraties occidentales on n' pas
réussi donc on ne peut pas les lâcher et
ensuite le fantasme du fait qu'on a
beaucoup aidé l'Ukraine c'est faux donc
jeis aller regarder en 2022 on était le
13e pays européen à aider l'Ukraine en
2023 on s'est de plus en plus désengagé
on était le 24e pays aujourd'hui on all
à 30e place on donne peinuts on a eu
soit 00 réfugiés c'est rien en Pologne
il y a 16 millions d'Ukrainiens qui sont
en
polne mais aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
Macron il est obligé d'un point vue
diplomatique et géopolitique de dire
nous on est quand même du côté des
Ukrainiens et on continue a Ukrainiens
c'est de la communication c'est tout gu
ce qui terrible effectivement c'est le
peu importe les efforts qui
hiérarchisent les problèmes qui
sousentend qu'en fait les agriculteurs
c'est important mais pas tant que ça les
gilets jaunes à l'époque c'était
important mais pas tant que ça en
revanche quand c'est l'Ukraine là c'est
nos limite et je trouve ça pas cohérent
comme discours ça veut dire qu'en fait
ils ont l'argent mais ils le sortent
uniquement quand ils le veulent Emmanuel
Macron je pense qu'il faut qu'il
comprenne qu'il n'est pas président du
monde mais président de la France mais
si il env l'Ukraine après s'il env la
moldav je dire ça commencé comme ça la
Seconde Guerre mondiale vous avez
montter sur vos grand chev en disant
mais non mais non mais hier vousz VO
ch VO ouais c pourtant très important
parce que c'est un des trucs de mémoire
et ben ça commence comme ça ça commence
par des petits pays comme ça tout le
monde sen F et on se lave les mains
incohérent de dire qu'on a pas d'argent
un moment se rend compte qu'en fait on a
des milliards quand on veut les investir
pour un problème qui semble important
que gine est faux moi j'ai d'autres
chiffres euh on parle des problèmes des
agriculteurs les importations moi aussi
j'ai j'ai pas les mêmes chiffres que toi
les moi je vais vous prendre les
importations agricoles entre 2021 et
2022 c'est passé de 12 à 15 milliards
d'euros on importe 15 milliards d'euros
de dé agricole d'Ukraine mais je vous
donne d'autres chiffres très
15 milliards d'euros volail miel sucre
euh là ça touche là ça touche vraiment
aux agriculteurs voilà donc là
on a un
Imp
confitreraine ets agriculteurs 15
milliards c'est énorme peut-ê là
Emmanuel Macron est justement à
Bruxelles pour infléchir la communauté
là-dessus il faut faire attention à un
moment on ne peut plus importer on ne
peut plus sauver l'Ukraine tout seul et
là on est en train de sauver
l'agriculture ukrainienne tout seul et
on peut
pas c'est exactement ça depuis que on
entend les agriculteurs les apiculteurs
sont en train de à cause justement des
importations de miel ukrainien là on va
avoir des des poulets Ukrainiens qui
arrivent en fait on nide pas les petits
agriculteurs ukrainien tous les poulets
viennent d'une énorme société
question j'ai une question à poseré avec
un pote très intelligent qui est à plein
de bon sens et qui m'a dit mais je
comprends pas en fait parce que les
poulets Ukrainiens en fait on n' pas le
droit nous faire des poulets comme en
Ukraine mais on a le droit de les
importer on a le droit de les vendre
donc en fait le poulet français on a pas
le droit qu'il soit comme celui de
l'Ukrainien parce que il y a des normes
européennes il y a des normes
écologiques tout ça qu'on peut pas faire
mais le poulet ukrainien tu le retrouves
quand même dans les supermarchés il est
moins cher que le poulet français donc
les Français ils vont aller choisir le
poulet on comprend pas normalement si le
poulet français peut pas fait comme le
pouletukrainien tu refuses l'importation
du poulet ukrainien puisque c'est pas
bon pour la santé mais le poulet on veut
bien qu'on mange du poulet pas bon pour
la santé ukrainien mais on veut pas
qu'on mange du poulet pas bon pour la
santé français donc là les gars on
marche sur la tête excusez-moi je sais
pas ce que tu pens on marche sur la tête
et bientôt le poul brésilien et bientôt
le pou sudaméricain qui sont
dégueulasses heureusement qu'on va
roncer àt le droit ils ontoit de de
faire comme il il respectent rien mais
on les met en rayon quand même incro
aucune norme aucune norme donc aucune
contrainte plus de la mainœuvre payé à
prix poulet français il il a 50000
normes et oui et donc il arrive deux
fois plus cher et aujourd'hui plus
personne ne pe acheter du poulet F
franais c'est le principal problème des
agriculteurs qui
vient a non mais là je parle c'est
c'estd que on a le droit de mettre en
rayon des poulets qui sont censés ne pas
être bons pour notre santé que c'est ce
qu'il nous disent mais comme c'est du
poulet ukrainien c'est pas grave si tu
crèves avec un poulet ukrainien on s'en
fout par contre si tu crèves avec un
poulet français ça c'est non mais les
gars arrêtez on marche sur la tête
excuse-m mais arrêtons l'hipocrisie
parce que nous ici on peut acheter les
produits français le problème des
produits français c'est qu'ils sont très
très ch par Y a ple
des ont 25000 normes parce que là-bas on
paye pas
la
g auourd'hi ont des
problèmad disent je achet franç par
jeendsuse agcurs concrètement
globalement ley il par c'est
trop le poulet ukrainien il a le droit
d'être en rayon c'est ça qui est fou
regardez sondage s'il vous plaît
d'accord AC lui bon voilà non
jeenseage 4 Milard Milard on ait un
sondage honneur on est d'un pays qui
nous poign dans le dos au gagé un
sondage merci mon ah allez